Vítej zpět v seriálu Kvantové výpočetnictví v praxi. Toto je epizoda 6. Dnes se zaměříme na jednu z mých oblíbených
aplikací kvantových počítačů – simulaci přírody. V této epizodě probereme kroky potřebné
k tomu pro jakýkoli druh problému kvantové dynamiky, což je problém nalezení toho, jak se popis
kvantového systému mění v čase. Nejprve to probereme na vysoké úrovni a pak se podíváme na konkrétní příklad a
projdeme ho podrobně – konkrétně experiment IBM z roku 2023, který demonstroval kvantovou užitečnost. Pro rychlou motivaci na
začátku – jeden z nejslavnějších příběhů, které my z oblasti kvantové výpočetní techniky opakujeme znovu a znovu:
příběh Richarda Feynmana, který v roce 1959 přednášel na Caltechu a v podstatě
poskytl motivaci pro celý obor na nadcházející desetiletí. Přednáška se jmenovala „There's Plenty of Room at the
Bottom" – vtipný název, ale základní myšlenka spočívala v tom, že tvrdil, že na mikroskopické úrovni je ještě
tolik bohaté fyziky k objevení.
Na tuto konkrétní přednášku se příliš neohlíželo až do 80. let, kdy se technologie výrazně rozvinula. A Feynman
také svou zprávu v průběhu času upřesnil a zdokonalil. V 80. letech se vrátil na Caltech a přednesl další článek nazvaný
„Simulating Physics with Computers" (Simulace fyziky s počítači), kde konkrétně řekl, že chce mluvit o možnosti, že existuje
přesná simulace – že počítač bude dělat přesně totéž jako příroda –
v podstatě schopnost zbavit se hrubých aproximací toho, co se děje na atomové úrovni, a nahradit je
počítači, které chápou a využívají kvantovou fyziku – nejen simulovat, co příroda dělá, ale emulovat to.
Vzpomeň si na tuto časovou osu, kterou jsem ukázala v předchozí epizodě. Na jednom konci jsme měli problémy, které je snadné
vyřešit a které nevyžadují žádné zrychlení, které by kvantové technologie mohly nabídnout. Ale na druhém konci máme problémy, které jsou
velmi těžké a potřebují odolné kvantové stroje, které ještě nemáme.
Naštěstí věříme, že existuje poměrně dost simulačních problémů, které leží zde uprostřed – v oblasti,
ve které můžeme v současnosti pracovat. A existuje spousta důvodů být nadšen a zaujat touto vyhlídkou, protože
simulace přírody je základem pro mnoho vzrušujících oblastí aplikací – abych jmenovala jen pár. Kdybychom mohli lépe
simulovat přírodu, mohli bychom urychlit objev nových materiálů, vytvořit lepší farmaceutické přípravky a léky nebo
dokonce prozkoumat novou fyziku podpírající fyziku částic nebo kosmologii. Ale než ty, já nebo kdokoli může zkusit
aplikovat kvantové výpočetnictví na tyto vzrušující oblasti, budete prozatím muset pochopit základní kroky v
typickém workflow založeném na simulaci.
Nejprve budeš chtít identifikovat kvantový systém zájmu. To tě informuje o Hamiltoniánu řídícím jeho časovou
evoluci a smysluplném popisu jeho výchozích vlastností nebo jeho stavu.
Pak budeš muset najít vhodnou metodu pro implementaci časové evoluce tohoto stavu. Jakmile jsou tyto ingredience
vyřešeny, další kroky zahrnují provedení samotného experimentu.
Ty obecně zahrnují optimalizaci implementace kvantového circuit pro algoritmus časové evoluce, spuštění
circuit nebo circuit na kvantovém hardwaru a post-processing výsledků. Takže
základní kroky zapojené do simulačního experimentu můžeme pojmenovat takto:
identifikace systémového Hamiltoniánu, kódování Hamiltoniánu, příprava stavu, evoluce stavu,
optimalizace circuit, spuštění circuit a post-processing.
Ale to jsou poměrně podrobné kroky. Pamatuj, že čtyři fáze rámce Qiskit patterns – který nám pomáhá
pochopit, jak implementovat rutinu v Qiskit – jsou: mapování, optimalizace circuit, spuštění circuit a
post-processing. Takže tyto první čtyři kroky jsou vlastně všechny zahrnuty pod zastřešující pojem mapování – a proto
jsme věnovali celou epizodu této první fázi. Pokud jsi ji zmeškal, prosím vrať se a podívej se na předchozí epizodu.
Nyní si nejprve projdeme, co tyto kroky vůbec znamenají, než se ponoříme do kódování. Takže první základní věc, kterou potřebujeme
udělat pro provedení simulačního experimentu, je identifikovat Hamiltonián popisující systém. Někdy –
spíše často – jsou tyto dobře known, jindy je musíme sestavit z pochopení energetických příspěvků
malých podmnožin celého systému, jako je tento, kde hi je Hamiltonián působící na jeden z n podsystémů h.
Také budeme muset zaznamenat, zda se systém skládá z fermionů nebo bozonů, pokud pracujeme s elementárními částicemi. Dál
potřebujeme zakódovat Hamiltonián a přeložit ho do termínů, kterým kvantové počítače rozumějí. Tyto
Hamiltoniány budou často složeny z elementárních částic nebo spinových systémů. Pokud bychom simulovali fermiony nebo bozony,
budeme muset zvolit transformaci kódování jako Jordanovu-Wignerovu nebo Bravyi-Kitaevovu. Tyto transformace nám
řeknou, jak přeložit definici Hamiltoniánu napsaného v termínech původních složek – fermionů nebo
bozonů – do Pauliho operátorů, které jsou snadno převedeny na gate na kvantovém počítači. Například Jordanova-Wignerova
transformace definovaná zde poskytuje mapování z fermionických operátorů na Pauliho operátory. Pokud již pracujeme
se spin-1/2 systémy, které jsou velmi běžné, pak jsme připraveni – krom možných normalizačních koeficientů –
a nepotřebujeme použít schéma kódování. Po zakódování požadovaného Hamiltoniánu do sady gate kvantového počítače
je dalším klíčovým krokem určení vhodného počátečního kvantového stavu, ze kterého začneme naši
simulaci. Tento stav by měl ideálně odrážet nějaký fyzický význam nebo konfiguraci
studovaného systému. Například, pokud nás zajímá prozkoumání energie základního stavu molekuly, mohli bychom
začít s Hartree-Fockovou aproximací nebo jiným snadno připravitelným ansatz, který má výrazné překrytí s pravým
základním stavem. Volba počátečního základního stavu ovlivňuje nejen konvergenci variačních algoritmů
jako VQE – variačního kvantového řešitele – ale také přesnost a efektivitu
časové evoluce nebo vzorkování v kvantové fázové estimaci. V podstatě počáteční stav slouží jako
odrazový bod pro výpočet, který nastavuje scénu pro extrakci užitečných observabilů o kvantovém systému,
který modelujeme. Příprava libovolného n-qubitového stavu, kde ci jsou stavy výpočetní báze a ai je
WEBVTT
příslušný koeficient každého stavu a normalizační podmínka 2 na n mínus jedna, lze obecně přistoupit
inicializací stavu operátorem o – výchozí stav by byl všechno-nulový stav standardní báze, często zapsaný
takto pro zjednodušení. Obecně to vyžaduje exponenciální počet C-NOT gate. Mnohokrát jsme
zainteresováni v konkrétním počátečním stavu systému a jeho příprava může být implementována s přiměřeným množstvím
zdrojů. Produktové stavy například, ve kterých qubitů nejsou vzájemně provázány, vyžadují pouze jednoqubitové
operace. Nyní jsme ještě neměli příležitost hovořit o trotterizaci,
i když někteří z vás ji pravděpodobně již znají. V podstatě trotterizace je metoda pro výpočet maticové exponenciace, která
používá aproximace pro zvládnutí exponenciální povahy nekomutujících operátorů. Když dva operátory jako HA
a HB nekomutují, musíme použít chytrý trik a alternativně aplikovat příslušné exponenciály
e na -i*HA a e na -i*HB po n
opakování. Alternující evoluční operátory jsou aplikovány. Nebudu zde procházet důkaz, ale přiložím odkaz
na pěkný jednoduchý důkaz tohoto tvrzení v popisu. Ale shrnutí je toto: časová evoluce je
důležitou součástí mapování také. Trotterizace rozkládá spojitou interakci na diskrétní kroky, které
lze implementovat na kvantovém počítači. Po vygenerování trotterizovaného circuit jsme konečně dokončili
krok mapování. Nyní můžeme přejít k optimalizaci circuit.
K tomu je potřeba splnit toto: musí existovat rozvržení qubitů, které mapuje virtuální qubitů
tvého circuit na fyzické na hardwaru. To je potřeba, protože hardware může mít konkrétní topologie,
které omezují přímou interakci fyzických qubitů. Přičemž implementace
kvantového circuit often předpokládá schopnost jakéhokoli qubitů interagovat s jakýmkoli jiným qubitů. Pak musíme vložit
swap gate podle potřeby k směrování interakcí mezi qubitů, které nejsou propojeny. Musíme přeložit
gate v našem circuit do architektura instrukční sady nebo ISA instrukcí,
které lze přímo spustit na hardwaru. Pak musíme provést optimalizace circuit k minimalizaci
hloubky circuit a počtu gate. Tento krok lze také provést na virtuálním circuit – circuit, kde qubitů
ještě nebyly namapovány na topologii zařízení. Ale pamatuj, že většina z toho se provádí automaticky za tebe v
Qiskit. Přesně jak, uvidíme v další části této přednášky. Po kroku optimalizace jsme připraveni spustit
circuit pomocí primitivu. Pro většinu simulačních experimentů nás zajímá pochopení změny
určitých vlastností systému v čase. Takže pravděpodobně budeš používat primitiv estimator, protože ti
umožní měřit střední hodnoty observabilů odpovídajících konkrétním vlastnostem. Pak
nakonfigurujeme nejlepší možnosti pro estimator, které mohou přidat techniky potlačení chyb a zmírňování chyb. Nakonec spustíme
experiment. Posledním krokem je post-processing všech dat. Ten extrahuje naměřené střední hodnoty nebo, pokud
používáš sampler, vzorkované rozdělení pravděpodobnosti ve výpočetní bázi. Pokud vše, co potřebuješ,
jsou střední hodnoty observabilů zájmu, lze je přímo získat z primitivu estimator
jak v jejich surových, tak v chybově zmírněných hodnotách. Mnohokrát pak budou naměřené střední hodnoty použity
pro další výpočty jiných veličin zájmu, které nevyžadují kvantový výpočet a lze je
vypočítat na klasickém počítači.
Nyní projdeme skutečný příklad z velmi vlivného článku, který IBM publikovalo před pár lety, nazvaného
„Evidence for the utility of quantum computing before fault tolerance" (Důkaz pro užitečnost kvantové výpočetní techniky před odolností vůči chybám). Tento článek, který s láskou zkracujeme
jako „utility paper" (článek o užitečnosti), se stal velmi vlivným článkem v oblasti kvantové výpočetní techniky téměř okamžitě po publikaci.
Celková teze článku je, že hlučný kvantový počítač produkoval přesné výsledky nebo střední hodnoty
pomocí 127 qubitů a 2 880 gate mimo možnosti metod hrubé
síly – tedy přesné simulace kvantových circuit spuštěných hardwarem. Tato práce byla
také důležitá, protože ukázala, že kvantový počítač lze použít k ověření nebo porovnání výsledků s jinými
přibližnými klasickými metodami pro kvantové simulace, jako jsou algoritmy tenzorových sítí, kde řešení
nebylo předem known. Co je také poměrně skvělé, je to, že nyní ostatní mohou pomocí IBM quantum systémů
v cloudu a Qiskit tyto výsledky sami duplikovat a ověřit.
Ukážu ti, jak přesně to udělat. Pro tento příklad se konkrétněji zaměříme na
kroky zapojené do mapování tohoto problému na vstupy, kterým může kvantové zařízení rozumět. V tomto případě budeme
simulovat dynamiku celkové magnetizace systému magnetických dipólových spinů na mřížce v
přítomnosti externího magnetického pole. Systém lze popsat Isingovým modelem s příčným magnetickým polem.
Modelujeme to parametrizovaným kvantovým circuit, kde parametry odpovídají laditelné hodnotě
spin-spinové neboli Z interakce a síle magnetického pole X. Nyní
se tento seriál jmenuje Kvantové výpočetnictví v praxi. Takže budeme také diskutovat o postupech v tomto experimentu,
které implementujeme, abychom výsledky co nejlépe zkvalitnili. Dál tedy probereme, jak odstraňovat
špatné qubitů – qubitů s nízkou věrností gate nebo časy dekoherence, které by mohly dramaticky ovlivnit
experimentální výsledky. Tyto špatné qubitů mohou vzniknout kvůli špatné předchozí kalibraci
nebo dvouúrovňovým systémům interagujícím s qubitů. Odebrání některých qubitů z hardwarové nativní topologie odpovídá
uvažování systému na mřížce popsané výslednou topologií. Také probereme vytvoření
parametrizovaného kvantového circuit, který implementuje časovou evoluci systému prostřednictvím trotterizace.
Pro tento účel bude důležité identifikovat provazující vrstvy, které jsou kritickou součástí pro hlavní techniku
zmírňování chyb, kterou budeme později používat. V tuto chvíli chci zajistit, aby ty jako divák věděl,
že můžeš sledovat vše, o čem budu hovořit, v tutoriálu odkazovaném níže a na IBM
WEBVTT
kvantové vzdělávací platformě. V tomto tutoriálu si možná všimneš, že jsme na začátku notebooku vytvořili sérii pomocných
funkcí, které lze později volat, aby nám trochu usnadnily život. Chci je zmínit
nyní – ne proto, že je to součástí oficiálního nebo formálního procesu, ale protože to je to, co experimentátoři often dělají
v reálném životě, aby jim pomohlo spouštět tyto typy experimentů. A také nám to ukazuje, jak budeme náš
problém ještě dál rozkládat. Funkce, které definujeme v notebooku, jsou následující: odebrání vazeb qubitů,
definice vazeb qubitů, konstrukce vazeb vrstev, konstrukce provazujících vrstev a nakonec definice trotterizovaného
circuit. Dál si povíme o vazbách vrstev, které pomáhají definovat, jak qubitů
interagují se svými sousedy během simulace. Naše kvantová zařízení používají něco, čemu se říká rozložení heavy hexagonal
– speciální vzor pro propojování qubitů. V tomto rozložení můžeme seskupit propojení nazývaná hrany do tří
samostatných sad, kde žádná dvě propojení ve stejné sadě nesdílejí qubit. To je
důležité, protože na reálném kvantovém počítači nemůžeme spouštět dvoiqubitové gate zároveň, pokud zahrnují
stejný qubit. Každý qubit může být zapojen pouze do jednoho gate najednou. Rozdělením
všech propojení do tří vrstev můžeme aplikovat dvoiqubitové gate přes celé zařízení ve třech
kolech, přičemž zajišťujeme, že žádný qubit není použit ve více než jednom gate na vrstvu. Tyto
gate implementují ZZ interakci z Isingova modelu a opakují se při každém kroku simulace – tzv.
Trotterově kroku. Twirling upravuje šum v zařízení tak, aby i jednoduchý model šumu
byl pravděpodobně přesný. To také umožňuje přesně naučit se model šumu a použít získané
informace a techniky zmírňování chyb.
Dál musíme ze svého možného seznamu fyzických qubitů, které můžeme použít pro
experiment, odebrat špatné qubitů. Jak jsem říkala, qubit se může stát špatným z různých důvodů. Někdy je to jen špatná
kalibrace – jednoduchá chyba, kterou lze vyřešit pouhým opětovným kalibrováním.
Někdy je to trochu složitější a souvisí s tím, čemu říkáme TLS – dvouúrovňová mezifázová
vada, která vede k fluktuacím parametrů qubitů a relaxaci. To lze
vyřešit zahřátím celého systému trochu a pak jeho opětovným ochlazením. Ale to chvíli trvá a přes cloud to
nelze udělat. Takže prozatím nejjednodušší věc je je jednoduše vyloučit z našeho seznamu možných fyzických
qubitů, které budeme používat. Které qubitů se nechová dle očekávání, lze snadno identifikovat z platformy IBM Quantum.
Charakteristiky qubitů tam můžeš vykreslit v platformě nebo je stáhnout jako CSV. Pak vytvoř seznam všech
qubitů, které chceš vyloučit, a jednoduše je odstraň ze seznamu celkových fyzických qubitů na zařízení.
Dobře. Nyní pokračujme s naším krokem mapování – generováním našeho trotterizovaného circuit. Jak jsme ukázali
dříve, trotterizace diskretizuje časovou evoluci do série kroků a musíme se rozhodnout, kolik kroků.
Zde zvolíme šest. Ale obecně strategií je vyvážit něco, čemu se říká Trotterova chyba – což je
algoritmická aproximační chyba – s chybou vznikající z dekoherence. Více Trotterových kroků snižuje aproximační
chybu, ale vyžaduje hlubší kvantové circuit, které zažívají více dekoherenčního šumu. Definujeme
circuit v termínech parametru theta – což je síla externího magnetického pole –, vazeb vrstev a
počtu kroků a qubitů a samozřejmě backend zařízení. Kvůli
závislosti magnetizace systému na síle externího magnetického pole je zajímavé
spustit simulaci při různých hodnotách síly magnetického pole, které se překládají do různých úhlů RX pro
rotaci RX v circuit. Nyní – po vygenerování našeho circuit – přejdeme k jeho optimalizaci.
Prvním krokem zde je definovat správce průchodů. Pamatuj, že v kontextu Qiskit SDK transpilace odkazuje na
proces transformace vstupního circuit do formy vhodné pro spuštění na kvantovém zařízení.
Transpilace obvykle probíhá v sérii kroků nazývaných průchody transpileru. Správce průchodů je objekt, který
uchovává seznam průchodů transpileru a může je spustit na circuit. Správce průchodů vytvoříš inicializací
objektu správce průchodů se seznamem průchodů transpileru. Na konci náš správce průchodů
vytvoří ISA circuit – circuit, který musí být zapsán v termínech architektury instrukční sady backend,
která popisuje circuit a gate nativní pro backend, ale postrádá informace o časování potřebné ke spuštění
circuit. Nyní jsme připraveni spustit náš circuit – to je třetí krok Qiskit patterns. Jak bylo řečeno dříve,
budeme zde rozhodně používat estimator jako náš primitiv volby pro tento experiment, protože chceme měřit
celkovou magnetizaci systému a odhadování střední hodnoty observabilů je přesně to, pro co byl estimator
navržen. V tomto kroku bude také klíčové specifikovat naše možnosti pro zmírňování chyb. Použijeme extrapolaci nulového šumu,
abychom dosáhli co nejlepších výsledků. Konkrétně v tutoriálu uvidíš, že specifikujeme dvě nebo více
hodnot faktoru šumu, při kterých se mají vyhodnocovat extrapolované modely, a specifikujeme
probabilistické zesilování chyb jako naši možnost zesilování. Nyní, probabilistické
zesilování chyb neboli PEA bylo skutečně metodou zmírňování chyb zvolenou zde, protože se škáluje tak mnohem
lépe než ostatní možnosti. A to je důležité, když pracujeme na úrovni 100+ qubitů.
V neposlední řadě spustíme experiment – chvíli to potrvá – ale prozatím se odvolávejme na data
uložená z tutoriálu. Prozkoumáme metadata, přičemž si zvláště všimneme vrstvených gate a
zmírněných vrstev, protože je za chvíli použijeme k odstranění spousty chyb z našich surových dat. Jsme téměř připraveni
vykreslit naše konečné výsledky. Ale než to uděláme, pojďme sem rychle zařadit mezihru o tom, co přesně se myslí extrapolací nulového šumu
neboli ZNE. Stručně jsme ji probrali v předchozích epizodách, ale pro zopakování: extrapolace nulového šumu
je technika zmírňování chyb, která odstraňuje účinky neznámého šumu během spuštění circuit, který lze
škálovat known způsobem. Předpokládá, že střední hodnoty se škálují se šumem pomocí known funkce zobrazené zde, kde
WEBVTT
parametry lambda specifikují sílu šumu a lze je zesilovat. ZNE lze implementovat pomocí následujících kroků.
Za prvé, zesiluj šum circuit pro několik faktorů šumu – lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3 a tak dále. Spusť každý šumem zesílený circuit k měření
střední hodnoty a(lambda 1), a(lambda 2) a tak dále. A pak extrapoluj zpět na limit nulového šumu
– střední hodnotu a(0).
Hlavní výzvou při úspěšné implementaci ZNE je mít přesný model šumu ve střední hodnotě
a zesilovat šum known způsobem.
Existují tři běžné způsoby, jak je zesilování chyb implementováno pro ZNE: škálování doby trvání pulzu pomocí kalibrace,
opakování gate v cyklech identity a přidávání šumu prostřednictvím vzorkování Pauliho kanálů.
Poslednímu říkáme PEA. Probabilistické zesilování chyb je zde nejlepší volbou, protože protahování pulzu je velmi
výpočetně nákladné. Skládání gate postrádá teoretické záruky při zachování zaujatosti šumu. PEA však lze
aplikovat na jakýkoli circuit, který lze spustit s nativními faktory šumu, ale vyžaduje naučení se modelu šumu. PEA předpokládá
stejný vrstvový model šumu jako probabilistické rušení chyb.
Vyhýbá se však vzorkovacímu overhead, který se škáluje exponenciálně s šumem circuit. Pro naučení se modelu šumu
musíme nejprve identifikovat unikátní vrstvy dvoiqubitových operací v circuit.
Pro každou vrstvu aplikuj Pauliho twirling na dvoiqubitové gate, abychom zajistili, že šum je dobře popsán modelem tlumícího šumu.
Opakuj páry identity vrstev při různé hloubce a nakonec přizpůsob věrnost nebo chybu pro každý šumový kanál. A
samozřejmě, i když doporučuji tuto metodu do určité míry pochopit, dělat to ručně v Qiskit je
mnohem jednodušší, jak je ukázáno v tutoriálu. Nyní se konečně podívejme na vykreslená data. Tečkovaná
šedá linie ukazuje přesné výsledky získané přibližnými klasickými metodami s aproximační chybou
konvergující na nízký práh. Jak vidíš, surová data pro různé faktory šumu, které jsme zvolili na
začátku, jsou poměrně daleko od této tečkované linie. Plná modrá linie ukazuje data zohledňující naše ZNE
zpracování. A hned vidíš, že je mnohem blíže přesným výsledkům.
Shrnuto, hlučné hodnoty vykazují vysokou odchylku od přesných hodnot.
Zmírněné hodnoty jsou blízko přesných hodnot, což demonstruje užitečnost techniky zmírňování založené na PEA.
A to v podstatě uzavírá tuto epizodu. Rychle shrneme, co jsme se naučili: kvantová simulace je jedna
z nejslibnějších oblastí aplikací v krátkém až střednědobém horizontu.
Má široce sahající aplikace od farmaceutiky přes fyziku vysokých energií,
materiálové vědy a další. Článek o užitečnosti od IBM z roku 2023 ukázal
cestu k možnosti využití kvantových počítačů pro vědecký objev. A prošli jsme
přidružený tutoriál, který k tomuto článku patří, do hloubky. Kroky pro práci na simulačním problému od začátku
do konce jsou relativně přímočaré, zejména jakmile si na to zvykneš. A doufám, že
od nynějška budeš moci toto video a tutoriál použít jako průvodce pro ještě více simulačních problémů v budoucnosti.
Díky za sledování a uvidíme se příště v seriálu Kvantové výpočetnictví v praxi.